okay short
break uh but let's move on so this is
kind of the
last uh new topic that we're gonna we're
going to cover uh this is the last last
Topic in the in the course before our
two guest lectures next next week and so
what we're going to talk about is um
symbolic regression and and model
Discovery uh yeah so like I said we just
we just had the introduction to Jack now
we're going to to be talking about
symbolic progression and model Discovery
for the last
part um so in this lecture I'm going to
tell you what model Discovery is how we
Define model
Discovery uh and then I'm going to talk
about symbolic regression as a way to
kind of solve this task of model model
Discovery and we're going to spend quite
a lot of time talking about the
challenges of symbolic regression and
why this is such a difficult task to to
achieve
uh we're also going to spend time
talking about function discovery which
is maybe a uh a con conceptually simp
simpler task before we think about model
Discovery um and then we'll talk about
kind of state-ofthe-art model Discovery
Discovery
systems um so yeah by the end of the
lecture hopefully you'll understand how
symbolic regression algorithms work or
designed all the kind of the important
Concepts that you need to uh understand
or the the kind of difficult challenges
that you need to solve for these types
of
algorithms and then we'll you'll
understand how we use symbolic
regression for function and model model
this
discovery okay so uh here's an equation
anyone know what this equation
is one person anyone else who's seen
this before hands
up okay so anyone wants to tell me what
this equation is
yeah Einstein's field equations for
general relativity yeah so this is
probably one of the most famous
equations in physics anyone can you can
anyone tell me what the left hand side
and the right hand side says like at a
highly conceptual
level maybe anyone anyone else
know okay go on
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah exactly yeah
so this is a really remarkable equation
but Einstein with the help of other
amazing physicist kind of eventually
worked out is it relates the kind of
curvature of the SpaceTime with the
stress energy and momentum content
within the
SpaceTime uh so basically saying that
like the physics or like uh gravitation
um depends on on Geometry and this is
like a super ground breaking idea that
uh you know has defined a lot of modern
physics
today I'm not going to go into details
of the equation but these are kind of
the terms uh that that we Define and it
includes things like the gravitational
constant the cosmological constant the
speed of light and other interesting
kind of physics physics quantities and
constants
um
so I guess the question that I'm ask in
this kind of lecture is What If
eventually uh maybe not today but maybe
in the future what if AI could help us
do this sort of thing like make these
kind of groundbreaking discoveries in
physics now I want to I want to carry
out this and say we definitely are not
at this level uh today in my opinion of
using AI to like discover relationships
between geometry and like matter I think
that that is uh relies on remarkable
human intuition um but I do think this
is an exciting field and I think we're
making some like steps towards this kind
of grand goal of like helping us to
discover physics or other kind of
fundamental scientific phenomena and how
they work and so what I'm going to try
and give you a flavor of in this lecture
is just some of the start kind of
starting ideas that people are trying to
to get towards this
goal and why would it be useful to have
an AI that does this well these are two
examples or reasons that I tried to tell
you in the first lecture uh of kind of
the struggle that that that we're having
as scientists today um in in doing
scientific discovery and and one of the
one of the challenges is the just the
sheer amount of data that some of our
experiments are producing so if you
remember this is a plot of the amount of
data and terabytes recorded by CERN the
particle collider like every month and
we're recording like thousands of
terabytes petabytes of of of data every
month and so a human it's just
impossible for like a person to go
through that dat by hand and look at all
the events and categorize them and try
and reason about those events so AI
could help us just like pull out
patterns and maybe at a more deeper
level kind of figure out some scientific
theory behind those
patterns another example is is the
complexity of the scientific problems
that we're studying like as we learn
more about scientific phenomena they
often get more complex and and again
there might be kind of hidden patterns
that ai ai could help us pull out that
we just wouldn't see before so example
this is kind of evolution of the the
covid virus and and uh this evolution is
incredibly complex and depends on you
know Global dynamics of of populations
and politics and everything else
so so yeah can can AI help us uh deal
with this data deal with the types of
problems that we're that we're trying to
solve
today so I'm going to Define two tasks
that um people are looking into to to
use machine Lear to help us and one is
uh
what I would Define as model
Discovery and there are different ways
to Define this but for the purposes of
this lecture I'm going to keep it simple
and and just
say given some observations of some
scientific or physical system let's just
take a very simple system that we've
already looked at so far and this is the
The Damp harmonic oscillator so imagine
that we're just watching the spring
oscillate and we have we make we take
measurements of its position through
time maybe we also know the mass of the
spring it's spring constant the the
dampening coefficient these sort of
things so given these observations the
task is to actually find an underlying
model uh that describes this system and
I don't just mean like a a functional
fit to this curve I mean like what is
the actual uh fundamental uh model that
describes the system and in this case
it's the this ordinary differential
equation forat can we actually discover
the whole equation itself
so a more conceptually simpler task but
still very challenging in my opinion um
is what I would call function
Discovery and so this is the task of
given some observations of some function
in general this could be a vector
function or even a vector valid function
as well so given like say n examples of
that function can we figure out what
it's actual mathematical expression is
so let's assume that that function has
like an analytical expression can we
discover
can we not just fit the function but can
we actually discover its mathematical
expression so you can see how that's
different to like standard function
fitting so anyone recognize these
equations can anyone tell me what any of
these equations
are
yeah ideal gas law yeah
anymore
yeah yeah y
yeah relativistic energy yeah did you
have your hand
up
yeah yeah Stephan bolman's law for black
body
radiation
yeah oh oh plank planks equation yeah
planks equation so I'll go through the
rest so you've got 's law the snow's law
this is the THM direct distribution for
ferons so yeah these are just examp
famous examples in physics of of
functions that you know we've we've
often derived by hand but say if we had
measurements of the temperature of a
black body in its surface area could we
actually discover what this uh what this
equation is that's or similarly if we
had uh observations of rays going
through different media can we and we
know their angles and their refractive
indices can we can we figure out what s
law is for
example so that that's the that's the
task okay so I've got a function here so
I'm going to give you a challenge of
guessing the punching so I'm going to
try something I haven't done before
hopefully this will
work so if you could all pull out your
your phones or your
devices we can try this also on for the
people on Zoom you can also have a go at
this so
present so what you need to do is just
scan this QR code and then it should
give you all of these options and you
can you can have a guess at what what
this function is
so I've got six different options for
you uh and I've given you some help
because each of the each of them have
things that the function looks like so
there are things like cosines there so
making the function oscillatory there
are some like linear dependence there
there's some
squares so tell me if it's working if
when someone votes hopefully it should
pop up but I've never tried this before
so
I'll give you a few
minutes oh great it's
working nice a couple of votes for X cos
pix s
give you a few more
seconds okay so I think most people have
gone for option three uh so X cos pi x
squ so anyone that went for that option
can you tell me why you chose that
option or what was your process
they're figuring
now
yeah
symmetry what do you mean
by
yeah
yeah yeah so that the x
s cos x gives you like an oscillatory
function the x s does what
it it changes the frequency of the
oscillation basically which is actually
what you're seeing here so yeah that's
good
yeah
yeah yeah
EXA yeah
yeah okay so you said yeah it's growing
it's it looks like a linear linear
growth here so it a good kind of guess
would be x times by something or a
linear dependence on X so this is got x
times cos x yeah so no one went for this
option maybe it's just too small to
see uh I put this in as a trick so this
is actually the tailor series of the of
the true function but you could have
chosen this and it' be correct
um yeah this is the this is the answer
so well done everyone that guesss guess
the option
three um so let's go back
to the
[Music]
presentation okay so uh this is the this
is the function and um I think it's
really interesting to like introspect
and think think about how we would do it
as as a human like how we would actually
guess this function given these
observations of the the function over
minus 3 to three say
so here's how I would have maybe done it
it's hard to say how I would have done
it because I knew what it was when I did
it but I probably would have guessed
that it's oscillatory to start with and
I would have also made the observation
that the frequency increases as X
increases so there's some
nonlinear uh uh dependence on X inside
of this clost
function also the amplitude is growing
linearly like someone just pointed out
um and based on all that then maybe I
would just actually to get the actual
coefficients of these functions I would
look at at the the actual values of Y
and try and figure out what the what the
coefficients would be and we would find
y x cos Pi
x^2 and so I just want to make the
explicit difference between symbolic
regression which is guessing the actual
mathematical expression and function
fitting function fitting would take
examples of this function and fit some
function to that
data so how would we how would we do
this with a nor Network we would just
say okay the function we're going to
assume what the what that mathematical
expression is rather than trying to
discover it and the thing in that
mathematical expression that we're going
to vary it just the coefficients inside
that function so maybe we would assume
that you know it's a a fully connected
network with some activation and we
would just learn the weights and biases
of the network so so we're only
discovering coefficients rather than
discovering the operators in this in
this mathematical expression everyone
clear on the difference that should be
obvious okay okay so my question is why
why is symbolic progression often harder
than doing this kind of function fing I
mean both are can be very complicated
and difficult tasks but why is this
often
harder
something you know change some
slightly yeah right so it can be very
difficult to use gradient descent for
symbolic progression and the reason is
because how do you do GR on a on a
symbol or operation it's like a
discrete operation instead of something
continuous to differentiate
yeah yep definitely any there are many
others many other reasons anyone anyone
thought of any
others
yeah yes can you expand on that
yeah yeah right so the search base is
much bigger so in here we assume we know
the number of coefficients uh that we're
fitting to generally here the expression
could contain
an like an infinite amount of operators
or maybe a very large number of
operators depending on the complexity of
the
expression okay so yeah
yeah so yeah so I'm going to explain uh
a lot about how we uh reduce the search
Spas basically and and allow us to
figure out what what the function is
that's one idea there are many good
ideas to
uh so so here's here's some of the
reasons um most of them you pointed out
so as you pointed out we need to learn
the whole expression and not just
coefficients and we may not know the
length of the expression so this is this
is really
challenging this is probably the biggest
challenge is that the search base in
general is
exponential just think of a if we can
describe a mathematical exess expression
is a
string uh where where the each uh
element of the string is like an
elementary operator Like A Plus or a
minus something like this then you know
basic com
combinatorial uh uh if you just look at
all the different combinations of all
those strings they're like s to the N
possible combinations so this is an
exponential suchar uh sech
space where we don't even know what n is
so yeah very
challenging and then the next one is to
do with the differentiability uh we're
now trying to search over operators you
know additions divisions multiplications
uh uh these sort of things and it's
typically not differentiable like how
how can we differentiate over an
operator that doesn't quite make sense
in my head there are ways to do it but
we'll talk about them
later um the other one that maybe you
didn't see is that I told you before
generally we just have a finite set of
examples of the function so you know a
finite number of training training
points of the
function so why why would why is this
statement true that with only a finite
number of observations there may be many
valid Expressions can
tells all these points exactly we can
always do a polinomial fit with however
many with n points or n minus one points
to to uh to fit the function perfectly
so it's it's illposed it might not give
us the true function that generalizes to
new new points for example
so we can overfit symbolic regression
just like we can overfit uh uh normal
function regression in exactly the same
sense
okay so we're going to go into details
like how do we solve how do we come up
how do we overcome these big challenges
in symbolic regression and uh and um
we're going to talk about it in terms of
function uh Discovery and then we're GNA
once we've talked about function
Discovery then the last half of the
lecture probably I'll cover on Friday
we'll talk about model Discovery how we
can use the same types of algorithms to
discover like differential equations as
well as just simple mathematical
Expressions so um one way to think about
mathematical Expressions uh and it's
very important to choose the right
representation um when we're defining
our search
algorithms uh so that we can like
efficiently search this space and so one
one representation is uh to think of
these mathematical Expressions as trees
who's seen trees before in like computer
science or or similar yeah
okay so it turns out we can write any
mathematical expression as a tree um and
we just say the tree has some root and
then has some branches uh and at each uh
kind of node on the tree we have an
operation and then at each Leaf of the
tree so at each end member here is just
a coefficient value so whether it's the
x value or if it's some other
coefficient so some some Scala value
here so you can see uh uh we can just
rewrite this whole expression as a tree
where the kind of the root of the tree
is this multiplication it's this x times
by this cause object here and then we
can decompose cause down into some other
lower level operations which is you know
pi times by x s and then X squ is also a
power
operation everyone see how that can just
be represented as a as a
tree so yeah like I said the root is the
is basically the final expression we
once we've got to the roote we can
evaluate the expression the noes are all
the operations and then the branches are
either unary or
binary so why why not have like a branch
of three why not have an operation with
three why can we just use binary and not
yeah
operations yeah yeah exactly most
operations can just be written as like a
two two inputs and one output or like
this down into their perimeter of
operations
yeah uh and then we can Define you know
General tree quantities things like the
depth of the tree the is an important
thing to to
know
okay so let me talk about the search
space and just tell you again why it's
such a large space what what I did here
is uh enumerate all the possible
expressions for trees that only have a
depth of
two and for a very very limited library
of possible operations so the expression
can only contain X there can't be any
other like scal coefficients in in the
expression and then it can only combine
plus multiply to the power of two
and already with just the tree depth of
two like in general the tree depth can
be 10
100 uh we have like 65 expressions and
you can just see how many Expressions we
have here it's interesting that some of
these are actually redundant like a uh
like X Plus X Plus X is like 4X for
example or like a I think there's some
better examples here yeah like x x x
time x x x is uh
like this this expression here if we
just collapse it down uh so that's
that's interesting maybe you can use
that redundancy to reduce this the space
but in general uh yeah this this is a
huge space as such you can imagine if I
increase the Tre depth just by one this
is going to go up probably in the
hundreds or thousands of of
Expressions
okay so how are we going to solve this
uh so what we need to do is uh we need
to what what is often called as pruning
the search
space so there's absolutely no way that
we can enumerate in a com combinatorial
way all of these possible expressions
and then test if each expression is
going to match our data that's just it's
just not
possible and so fundamentally whatever
whatever task we're doing in symbolic
regression we usually have to do
something like this where we have to
assume some structure of the trees we
have to prune the trees
say for example that they have a a less
number of operations or a small number
of coefficients or more more in general
we just have to assume some some subset
of the possible structure of trees that
we're going to search
over does this make sense we're defining
uh in a problemistic way we're defining
like a prior like all the possible
versions of the the Expressions that we
we expect the expression to to
satisfy so who's heard of oam's Razer
hands
up okay so this is like a often stated
in the wrong way but uh usually right is
uh the simplest explanation is usually
the best one this is like a really
famous famous quote or kind of
observation so yeah I mean we we looked
at um overfitting in the Deep uh deep
learning lectures and I talk to you
about this kind of bias variance
trade-off between uh machine learning
models where as you increase the model
complexity often the error goes down but
then the variance or basically the
susceptibility to overfitting goes up of
the model and so we argued that there
was like some sweet spot where the model
doesn't overfit but still has a good
good error so like we're choosing the
kind of optimal model
complexity this is just a fun fun uh
poker conspiracy theories like
uh they are e theory and perhaps they're
true but you the amount of evidence
against those Theory makes it very hard
to explain the theory and maybe a razor
could be applied to these
things
okay right so at a high level uh before
we talk about specific symbolic
regression algorithms um these are the
requirements that we need to solve the
symbolic progression problem for for a
large difficult problem we need these
two things we need most importantly we
need an assumption on what the structure
of the expression is going to be so that
we don't do a combination combin notori
search and then we need to Define some
search algorithm that can efficiently
search through those possible structures
that we've defined and eventually
Converge on the on an expression that
fits the data that we that we
have so this is a huge kind of area of
research by its own bright and there's
you know a couple of review papers if
you want to go deep into this field I
definitely recommend looking at these
research papers they describe many
different papers and research directions
on both of these two points the search
algorithm and and the
assumptions so we're at the end of
today's lecture so I'll pick it up and
and go into this on
Friday so obviously see you then thanks
for
com okay so we're going to carry on uh
talking about symbolic progression and
model
Discovery let me remind you what we were
talking about last lecture so we started
off by thinking about this maybe cons
conceptually simpler uh idea which is to
discover functions or to discover the
mathematical expressions of functions
and once I've done talking about this
then we'll move on to how we actually
dis how we could discover actual
scientific models so not just functions
but like underlying differential
equations that kind of govern a
system so we're talking about uh the
specific task so given some observations
of a function and so just assume we have
n examples um can we actually derive it
mathematical expression and not just fit
the function so actually figure out the
the mathematical
expression and these are kind of some
example famous expressions in physics
that you know tell us about different
physical
systems um so can anyone remember why
it's often harder to do kind of symbolic
progression and just to fit this
function we talked about this last
lecture can anyone remember the
challenges can anyone tell me a
challenge yeah big search space big SP
search space yeah
yeah the search base is exponential so
yeah really hard to search interactable
in fact yeah any
others
yeah
yeah yeah search Bas is not
differentiable so a small change like a
change of one operator can dramatically
change the uh the function yeah any
others yeah
yeah or so given end data points there
are many possible functions that could
fit it yeah so it's ill posed yeah okay
so you've uh I think you've got
everything so the other one is that we
don't know what the length of the
expression is so even the the search Bas
is exponential but we don't even know
how big the search space
is um there's not a smooth interpolation
and yeah there's a many valid
Expressions given a finite number of
points
Okay so then we I showed you that we can
often think of these Expressions as
trees this is a lot of uh approaches
that try to do symbolic regression use
this kind of tree
representation where the nodes are the
tree of the operations and then we
either have binary operations or or
unary
operations and then the leaves of the
tree are the the reals either the
coefficients or the variables
themselves and uh I said well I showed
you all the possible expressions for a
tree depth of two for this very small
library and we're already getting like
60 65 expressions and you could see how
this will grow very very large very very
quickly if we increase the library and
if we increase the depth of the
expression okay so then I showed you
this idea that we're never going to be
able to search that whole exponential
search space it's just impossible um and
so what we have to do no matter what
symb symbolic regression algorithm we
choose we have to ruin the tree or we
have to basically assume some prior
structure of this expression to give us
like some sort of a chance to be able to
search the space
attractively so we can we can do many
different types of pruning can anyone
think of any ways you might try and
simplify the search
space if you think about trees how do
how would you simplify this
tree kind of a weird question
any ideas
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah so you could
just uh start with like so this might
say that we have some prior guess of
what the structure of the equation
should be so maybe we know that it
should be a coine expression for example
but we don't know the frequency of the
expression another thing we can do is
just part off the tree to a certain
depth so we can just say the expression
has to have no a depth of no more than
five or 10 or
something um or we can reduce the number
of possible operations in the
tree so the size of the
library so as we go through and I show
you these types of methods you'll you'll
hopefully understand the different ways
we can kind of restrict this search
SP so yeah these are the requirements to
successfully solve problem we need an
assumption on the kind of structure of
the expression and then we need some
search algorithm and there's a lot of
innovation in these two areas and what
is interesting is these two are kind of
independent choices you can have many
different types of assumptions and you
can mix and match them with many
different types of search algorithms and
it's kind of interesting to see which
choices are the best for the problem
that you
have so what we're going to do first is
we're going to think about the first
requirement so how are we going to
put a prior on the structure of the
expression so I'm going to talk about
one approach there are many as I just
said and if you're interested more
deeply you can kind of read these review
papers or state-of-the-art papers at the
bottom here they they go into it in more
detail um so who's heard of AI findan
just put your hand up if you've heard of
this
paper maybe okay one not maybe one okay
so this is a really nice paper I
definitely recommend reading it um and
this is a way to search for underlying
simplifications of the function that
you're trying to uh to to to
find so before we do a search algorithm
what we're going to do is we're going to
look for kind of hidden simplicities
that we can kind of derive from the
function uh that we're trying to
discover so let's just take a you know a
classic classic function from physics
this is uh Newton's law of gravitation
uh between two masses and so this this
expression just describes the force
given their their masses and the
gravitational constant and their
distance between the two
objects so if you look at this function
what's what kind of what makes this
function simple can anyone just kind of
tell me why this function is maybe
simple yeah symmetry symmetry what do
you mean by
that that's
yeah okay this there there's a
fundamental symmetry here that's
absolutely correct yeah so so the force
on this mass is the same as the force on
this Mass how does that kind of show up
in this
expression
yeah very very nice so another way of
saying that is the force only depends on
the the distance between the objects so
there's some kind of like trans
translational symmetry here it doesn't
depend on the absolute Valu of X2 and X1
that's that's what that's really good
observation there's there other
simplicities uh what do you mean by that
it's a rational
function yeah
yeah yeah so there's two po two pols
here uh that's that may be related to
something I'm going to tell you about in
a minute so that's good any think else
yeah yeah that's really good so one
thing we do in physics all the time is
dimensionality uh
analysis so what it means is the units
must match so the you know this is
Newtons here and we need to have some
sort of combination of these units of of
mass and the gravitational constant and
distance to turn it into a Newton unit
so yeah that's definitely a constraint
that we can exploit
okay so that's really good so the first
thing I'm going to do is talk about this
this thing your observation that the
units must match so yeah Newtons for the
force then the gravitational constant
has this uh this unit then the mass is
kilograms and then the distance is
meters
squar
so what we can do in physics and we do
this quite often is because we know that
the units must match we can TR we can
always transform this function into a
dimensionist function
so we can make it dimensionless and you
can see how we can do this by just
dividing uh you know the so remember
remember the function that we're trying
to discover here is um we don't know
what this expression is that's the
Assumption so but we do know that it's
some Scala function is a function of G
M1 M2 X1 X2 y1 Y2 Z1 Z2 and we know we
know we're assuming that we know what
the units of all of these variables are
and the unit of
F and so so we can dimensionalize all of
these variables M1 can just be divided
by some constant which has a unit of
mass in this case uh yeah so we divide
for example M2 by M1 M1 up here so we we
have this uh kind of non-dimensional
constant as well with the
function and so if I rewrite it in this
way uh we can just say that F this
unknown unknown function we have we know
that it can be written as some constant
some non-dimensionalizing constant uh
Times by a function which is a function
of a b c d e and f these non-dimensional
units can everyone see how we can kind
of write rewrite it in this way and this
is true for any function where we know
know that the units must match it can be
written as a constant times by some
function of some
non-dimensional
variables so can anyone tell me tell me
what this does to the search base if we
can say okay no the units match we can
rewrite f as constant times by some some
non-dimensional function here what have
I just done to the search
Bas spot on yeah so if you look at this
function now I've reduced the number of
uh inde dependent variables of the
function so it's gone from 1 two 3 four
five from 9 to six yeah like you said
and it's because some of these variables
are now just pulled out into this
constant at the front of the function so
um so so now we just have to search for
a function which is much lower
dimensional and that dramatically
reduces the search base the number of
possible combinations of these input
variables so yeah reduces the number of
variables so the question is how do we
given that we don't actually know what
the mathematical expression of the
function is how can we figure out what
these dimensionist variables are and
what the constant is in front of the
function I'm not going to go into how
that's done but there is a a
deterministic way to do that so you can
do this for every every function and uh
I'm just taking that to be true true for
now
okay so next imetry or next hidden
Simplicity is the we talk about this the
trans trans uh translational
symmetry so this is just the property
that it doesn't this this function
doesn't depend on the absolute values of
the positions it only depends on the
distance between them so how do you
think we can exploit
that or how might that reduce the search
base how how could you reduce the search
base given that
observation yeah
yeah absolutely so we can do a simple
change of variables where uh we
substitute r or D the difference between
these two instead of the two variables
themselves and then we again we reduce
the number of variables that the
function depends
on
um so yeah I just give I've just asked
that question and you told me the answer
so if I just plot f of x so what I can
do is I can query this function and I
can just test it for X1 and X2 and I can
see that the the output function is like
a linear
function and that's telling me that we
have translational
symmetry um so in this case we can like
you said we can substitute in uh D1 D2
D3 is just X2 - X1 Y2 - y1 uh like this
and then we've you can see how we're
reducing the function again to from six
variables down to one two three four
uh six where have I got wrong here
oh yeah so I'm not assuming
here so I'm not assuming here we did the
dimensionality analysis but if we did it
would have reduced it even further so we
just assuming we haven't done a
dimensionality analysis here and we're
just using the translational symmetry
that gets us down to six variables
instead of nine just like we did before
in the
dimensional
um but we need to know that that's true
so how how can we test for symmetry like
if if you're able to query this
function any set of variables how how
could you test that this property is
true that f of x f when of X2 and X X1
is just some function of the difference
between the
two
yeah yeah
yeah I think I think you're basically
right so so what you can do you just
choose some constant a so and then you
for all values of X1 and X2 or actually
all values of the input function you can
add a to these two and if it equals the
same as the the function without a added
to X1 and X2 then then you can if you
stare at that long enough you you'll
you'll realize that that tells you that
it's symmetric
well that's a sufficient condition to to
show that this is
true
okay there's another one that we haven't
uh talked about which is the
multiplicative separ separability so
what do I mean by that can anyone
guess this function is
separable how is it
separable yeah
yeah exactly so the top the numerator
here only depends on masses this only
depends on on the differences so another
way of saying that is we can we can
rewrite this function as some function
which only depends on G another function
which only depends on M Etc in a
multiplicative way so we' kind of
separated out these different factors in
the
function so again how does this if we
knew that this was the case for this
function how would we how does this
reduce the search space can anyone tell
me
so what we've done here is we've now
decompos this function into four
separate
functions and suppose that I knew the
first three
functions then all I would have to do is
learn a function which has less
variables than the the initi
function so what it actually allows us
to do is to carry out four independent
searches for for this so if we knew that
this is the case we can just fix the
values of X1 X2 y1 Y2 zed1
Z2 uh and then just search for these
these three or even go further fix the
value of M1 and G and then just search
for this I as a function of M2 and then
once we've figured out what I have a
function of M2 is we can do the same for
the other other three
functions so this this again makes the
search problem a bit simpler yeah
know if you just if you fix the value
you would still you still query the
function M2 here and you get like some
varying function that you could then do
a just a a symbolic progression and just
in regards to
N2 I I'll show you so the way that you
can test this basically if this is
true is a is a very it's kind of a
similar test to that trans transtion
symmetry that if you uh fix the values
of of one of one parameter and just vary
the one that you want to test for
separability and you compute this for
all values of X and show that it just
equals this as if you didn't fix the
values then then it's separable and
again this is a sort of thing if you
stare at it for long enough you can see
that it it it is sufficient to show that
there uh it's it's separable
okay
so that's worth going back to and just
convincing yourself that this is this is
true and and again if you go into the
paper they explain how they do these
sets of the
function so just to summarize how this
is working
is we start off with some mystery
function which we know is a function of
of these nine
variables and then we do each of these
kind of hidden Simplicity tests on the
function so the first test that we do is
a dimensionality analysis and we realize
that we can write it as some constant
times by a function that is non non
non-dimensionalized with a smaller
number of
variables now that we know that that's
the uh function we're looking for then
we do symmetry testing on that function
and we figure out that G and H
translationally have translational
symmetry that get that allows us to get
rid of another scale another variable
then we do our separability testing we
find that we can SE separate out a uh we
can separate out a
here um and that's as far as that's as
far as it goes at which point we then
have to bring in a search algorithm to
try and figure out this final function
which is only a function of three three
variables um given our you know our
examples of the function that we that we
have
available so then this AI fan does a bre
Force search but um you can use any
search algorithm if you if you like
and then that brief Force search will
then give us the kind of final
mathematical expression hopefully if it
converges and then we resubstitute all
of our variables or the kind of uh
variable Expressions that we've we've
discovered and we eventually end up at
the final
expression so can people see how by you
know simply just testing the function
for these kind of simplicities that we
can really reduce the kind of final
function that we actually need to
discover good
okay so this is the full workflow from
the from the paper it's a bit uh more
complex the actual algorithm they they
designed but it it's basically doing all
those different tests that I said and
then if those tests don't pass then it
has to rely on some brute force uh to to
solve to solve the
problem so you might notice that they
also train in network in here which
seems like it's completely different to
what I just described but they don't
actually the only reason why they train
a network here is they just fit it on on
that observational data of the function
that we have just to directly
approximate the
function and this just allows us to to
query the function at any point in X so
it's like an interpolation of those
those observational values remember we
have to query the function to do these
separability tests like whether it's mul
uh uh whether it's has symmetry or if
it's
separable so the network here isn't
doing anything like trying to understand
the symbolic expression or anything like
this it's just a function fitting
um and yeah just the key takeaway is
that this approach looks for ways to
simplify the expression before we search
for that final mathematical
expression okay so there's a problem
possibly is um these simp Simplicity
tests might just fail if the expression
doesn't have any of these uh kind of
hidden
simplicities and this algorithm it basic
version just relies on Brute Force so
it's then just going to take this
unknown function them do a a Brute Force
combinatorial search across our our
library of operators to try and find
that
expression and so what I'm going to move
on to now is is to think about different
search algorithms that are not just
combinatorial that might help us solve
these problems
better so yeah I've given you uh uh one
idea on how
to make some assumptions on the
structure of the expression what aian
does is actually allows us to discover
those actual underlying simplicities of
the
function any questions on this before I
move on to talking about search
algorithms
yeah yeah yeah that's a really good
observation so in practice F
observations of f have noise and this
right might really mess up our our tests
so that they in the paper they have kind
of thresholds right so so when you're
for example when you're doing something
like this you're querying the function
at many points and testing if this is
true it's not actually a perfect equals
they'll just have some threshold that's
based on the magnitude of the the
function or something so yeah that's a
good good observation the other the
other thing is when they use the noral
network here to fit the observational
data that actually can smooth out the
noise and kind of fit like a smooth
approximation and make it more
stable
y any other
questions
okay
so search algorithms can anyone think of
a better search algorithm that's not
just combinatorial
search who knows of other like search
algorithms that
work or just general search algorithms
that might not require gradients like
gradient research algorithms which ones
have you studied
before
again oh sorry I still
didn't okay yeah I haven't I'm not sure
I've heard that yeah any
others conqur and divide yeah yeah
yeah that breath search so you're
thinking of like tree search algorithms
kind of yeah yeah so you might start at
the root the tree and do a depth first
search or bre first search yeah
interesting any
others so who's heard of yeah
on minimum man tree yeah
yeah so yeah so you suggested quite a
few tree search algorithms so you're
assuming that we're trying to search a
tree
um we are kind of doing that but we're
actually just searching for trees it's a
bit of a
search problem it's not like we're
searching through the tree to find like
a end node of the tree we actually just
want to discover the whole tree itself
it's a slightly different search but I
can see where you're coming from um
who's heard of genetic
algorithms yeah everyone so well most
people yeah so genetic algorithm Super
Famous used for many different problems
and there are gradient free
method
um so this is what we're going to talk
about next is a is a better way to
search for these expressions using
evolutionary research or genetic
algorithms
so how is a genetic algorithm like Pro
uh searching this searching this space
more cleverly than just doing a
combinatorial
search so what the search does is it
relies on some hor istics some like some
observations that are may be empirical
but help us search the space in a
principled way than than just doing a
comor
search and so one of theistic that that
uh you could use when uh to when you're
searching these trees to find a find the
correct tree that represents the
expression is you could say well say
that we we have this tree uh here and we
look at how well it predicts our
observations here and this is uh this
expression is X Plus cos Pi x^ s and we
see oh actually this expression is doing
a fairly good job of fitting our data
it's got the OS lat Behavior but it's
got like a con it's got like a linear
Behavior instead of like a or like it's
it's constantly increasing instead of
being centered around
zero um and so the idea here is that
maybe the true expression might look
very similar to this tree but maybe we
just got one of the operators wrong and
so what we might do in the search is
instead of like just doing combinatorial
search like varying each of these across
its range in a in a big Brute Force way
is maybe we would just take one of the
operations and just mutate it and
basically just randomly change the
operation and our kind of horis or
assumption is that that might be a
better way to get us to the true the
true
expression and so you can see here that
this is the case if I just mutate uh the
top the top the the top node here we
actually do discover the the perfect
expression so everyone understand how we
could use a mutation in the search
algorithm to to inside the search
yeah can anyone else think of any other
genetic algorithm inspired changes we
can make to these Expressions
yeah
cross yeah so another classic thing
that's exactly right so another classic
thing in genetic search this to do
crossover uh so I have that as the next
slide so so a crossover is is slightly
different it says okay say that we have
these two expressions and that we know
that they're fairly close to the
solution but not perfect let's do a
random crossover so let's take maybe a
sub a sub tree of the of of the two
trees and and swap them over and you
could see how you could do this
crossover for any kind of random sub
tree that you're picking in the in the
trees so we take this this sub tree
which in this case is just a leaf and
then we just flip it with this smaller
sub tree here and and rebuild the
expression based on that and again you
can see if we do this I mean I've picked
this to work work but of course but if
we do this we end up with the correct
expression at the bottom here after that
cross who's with
me
okay any
questions yeah we
said yeah IDE
ofation
dire how does it apply yeah I mean so
you're making a very valid observation
so I said to repeat so I said at the
start one of the challenges is the
search Bas is not differentiable or
another way of saying that is there's
there can be big changes in the function
if you just flip one of the operators
and that is exactly what we're
suggesting here is that actually if you
just flip an operator you might get
close to the final final result so I
think this just depends on the the types
of functions and the types of libraries
that you're searching over but for sure
this is not guaranteed to converge any
faster than a Brute Force for some for
some
yes Solutions and then you continue
those yes but then what I'm saying is
that that solution that might be the
best up to this point you might
something yeah no I agree with you I
think this is a limitation so this is
why it's so horis it's like our guess at
what is a good direction to move in the
search Bas but it might not always be
the best one and it's probably not
provable that it's the best one I think
crossover is a bit more interesting um
uh one way you can think of crossovers
what I think makes it powerful is we're
not just flipping a single uh operation
but we're actually maybe you could think
of this as like shifting around
mathematical abstractions
like for example this might be the
subtree if you think about that
Newtonian um forces uh example that I
just showed where one of the
calculations was the um radius or the
difference between two
points maybe the genetic algorithm might
realize that that's a good abstraction
to use and maybe that would be the bit
that's crossed over to different uh
other Expressions that it's testing so I
think this is quite powerful it's like
reasoning on the abstraction matter what
abstraction level which is kind of
interesting
but yeah good good points any other
questions
okay so yeah this is how we would
actually write a genetic search
algorithm for for searching for
expressions
and um what we do is is this kind of
this this uh this pseudo code so what we
would do is actually we would start with
a a random population of trees this is
just a random population of mathematical
expressions
and then we would start this
evolutionary Loop so it it's just a for
Loop and generally we would select the
fittest
trees uh and one way to select the
fittest trees would be based on their
test error so you just measure given the
data points of the function how close
what what's the what's the uh mean squ
error for
example and then we apply these genetic
operations to those fittest trees so we
might do a mutation of one of them or we
might cross over randomly um uh some of
the some of the trees
together and then we would have to have
some notion of the oldest trees this
might be the ones that have not never
had uh genetic operators or might have
very low Fitness we would remove those
and then we would just keep looping and
the kind of idea of evolutionary search
or genetic search is this kind of
mirrors what happens in in biology it's
kind of the same this is what inspires
these
algorithms so we do that until we meet
some
convergence criteria it could be just
number of steps or it could be that
we've got Fitness above a certain
threshold and that's the
output any
questions that makes sense to everyone
yeah okay
so here's a really cool video um so this
is pi symbolic regression hands up who
who's looked at this liary before one
person yeah so this is uh written by
Milos kler he's done some really amazing
work in this in this field along with
many other
researchers so this
is his library that he's got on GitHub
so you can go and play with this and
this video is taken from from that
GitHub
page um and it's a symbolic progression
library and the main engine that does
symbolic progression here is genetic uh
search so what you're seeing here is uh
you know observations of some uh of some
true function and this is how this
evolutionary search algorithm is is
evolving over over
time um so it's you can see in the
background I guess it's meant to
represent all all the trees in the
population that are evolving over time
uh but this is um this algorithm has a
lot more added on top of it than just
that basic pseudo code that I showed you
one thing that it does uh inside that
for Loop um sometimes it will choose
instead of doing a mutation it will
choose to do some constant optimization
so the leaves here that it it adds to
the Expressions some of them are
constants and obviously they need to be
kind of tuned to their values and and he
does a a constant optimization randomly
at some steps to try and optimize those
before carrying on the genetic search so
that's what you're seeing in these kind
of constant optimization
steps so really really impressive
Library definitely worth having a look
at um and playing around with it's
really really interesting to see how it
how it
converges okay
so uh I probably don't have time to get
into this but uh this code P um also
runs in parallel across multiple threads
and what each thread is doing is
actually uh evolving its own separate
population um for a number of steps and
then at some point in the algorithm
those those separate populations cross
over they kind of fittest individuals
and then you kind of get this tournament
selection algorithm it's kind of a a
more complex ver of this genetic
search there's a lot more to be said
about this but I I don't have the time
so okay so I've talked about um other uh
genetic search there are also many other
search algorithms that I don't have time
to talk about um but I'm just going to
give you a quick fire idea of what these
other search args might be so again the
goal is to find F given our data set so
one way to do it is just to do it
directly to not actually have some like
full loop of a search going on
but just to take all those observations
as input and just try and learn some
model that spits out the expression at
the at the
end and Transformers may be a very
interesting model to do that because you
could think of these mathematical
Expressions as actually like a language
right we have like some sort of grammar
which is the kind of operations of the
inside the
expression so we might think of using a
Transformer with it kind of attention to
like attend to different parts of these
expressions and help us kind of derive
what the expressions
um so there's a lot more to be said but
that's a very interesting kind of
method um another whole idea is to use
reinforcement learning again this is
another whole kind of field of P of
symbolic progression and this is to say
okay we have some environment and the
environment is the tree that we're
searching and uh we have an agent in
that environment that is going to pick
the next node or the next operation in
that tree and it's going to pick that
that uh that uh extension to the tree
based on its observation of the tree so
far and the kind of test error and and
uh uh such such like
that um so the agent takes a number of
steps in this environment adding adding
noes to the tree and building this
expression and then it's trained with
some reward at the end of it so did it
match the expression or not so you can
kind of see how that that would be
framed as a reinforcement learning
problem you can also learn Tre search
algorithms you mentioned a few you can
kind of think of this as a tree search
as well
uh but if you have a look at this review
paper they again they they uh split out
all the possible different search
algorithms that people have proposed and
there's a there's a lot going
on okay so um I'm going fast because we
haven't got much time left so um I'm
I've got one example of or maybe two
examples of model discovery that I'm
going to try and explain to you quickly
um but if I don't get the chance then
just have a look through the slides and
and uh lat later there
so yeah we're going to take a break so
model Discovery is this idea of finding
the actual model rather than the the
function itself and so in this case we
have operators we have differential
operators that apply to these these
variables rather than just simple kind
of add additions Transformations
Etc so we can still use symbolic
regression all of those methods I just
talked about to try and discover these
models these underlying equations but
what we usually have to do is we have to
add extra operators so we add the
derivatives as as another possible
operator that we can apply to this
tree this makes it harder and so we have
to add some kind of domain constraints
on top of this usually to help these
these methods
converge
um so this is Cindy hands up who's heard
of Cindy this is quite a famous
algorithm so what it does is it tries to
find the equation for dynamical systems
that have this form where you just have
you say uh it's an ordinary differential
equation so DX by DT where X can be a
vector basically the state of the
system uh is some is some Vector
function here and what they assume in
the paper is that you have many examples
of both the the rate of change of X and
of the uh and of X
itself so uh an example is uh the Loren
system
so this is an example X here in this
case is the path of this uh of this
system behaving in this way and it's a
chaotic system so it's really
interesting to study but you can plot
the path through through its uh phase
base here and so what we're just saying
is we have lots of observations of its
position in this uh in the phase space
and also um of its velocity as it's
moving
around so what you can just realize is
that we just have measurements of X the
derivative of x and um of X
itself and so you just transform this
into saying here's this is our data we
have measurements of X and both the
derivative which is f and this just
turns into a standard symbolic
regression task without any derivatives
in it the only difference here is that
we're trying to find a vector value
function instead of a scalar function
and people see how that is kind of if I
know what uh DX DT is or if I have
observations then all I need to do is
find F
um so yeah we just assume Cindy makes an
assumption on the structure of the of
the function it assumes that we have
some library of of of
coefficients and that that function can
just be written as a as a as a
multiplication of that library with some
uh Matrix which holds all the
coefficients of those of those uh of
those Library functions inside of
it so an example for the Loren system we
could just write F ofx here uh is just
this library of operators here Times by
this coefficients Matrix here and this
kind of transforms the task into just
learning what these coefficients are
this coefficient
Matrix um so what you do is you just uh
take all your training data for each of
your training inputs you just compute
all these these Library operators so you
just take X you take y Zed all the
different operators you compute all them
into a matrix
you put into this Matrix here just your
observations of the Velocity that you
have already and then from this
expression we know that F can just be
written uh uh as the your your basis uh
uh Matrix here Times by these
coefficients and and the coefficients
are the things that we don't
know so how how would you solve how
would you find the coefficient Matrix
there who would what would you
do gradient descent yeah is is there a
better way what does this look like to
you this Matrix
equation
yeah aggression exactly it's linear
aggression so we know what this Matrix
is it's just all of our operators
applied to X which we know so it's just
linear regression so we just do Matrix
inversion we we can also use the fact
that we we're prior that we think the
coefficients are probably sparse you can
see there's a lot of zeros here that
we're not going to use all the about
operators in our
library so we can carry out sparse
sparse linear
aggression um so uh I'm gonna I'm well
I'll go through very very quick so Cindy
is using what's the assumption that it's
making on this task we're assuming that
the Expressions have this form which is
very restrictive and also that we have a
set a certain library that we've Chosen
and then the search algorithm that we
use is just Spar linear aggression like
lassu or R agression something
this okay I'm going to start because we
haven't got much time so uh this is a
really interesting extension of Cindy uh
which says it takes it a step further
and says if we have not observations of
the state itself but maybe some uh some
transformed version of that of that
state say that for example in this
equation the state is the angle of a
pendulum what if we just have images of
the pendulum moving through time it
turns out you can even discover given
this kind of video of the of the
physical system you can even discover
the underlying iCal
system and they do this by assuming or
learning some decoder that takes or
encoder that takes your image to your
lat to your uh State
space okay so um I don't have the time
for this
but so yeah it's it's unfortunate we
don't have more time to talk about
symbolic regression there's a it's a
huge field by itself and it's a really
interesting new kind of direction of
using AI to kind of discover physics or
help us understand physics more deeply
than just doing kind of some function
fitting or Black Box model prediction
with a with a
network
um okay
so I'm G to spend maybe just three
minutes just doing a quick summary if
you have time but if you need to leave
feel free to leave that's that's that's
it
um so yeah we've gone through a massive
journey in this course um we've covered
a huge amount of different topics in in
uh in scientific machine learning in AI
for science in general and these were
kind of our our learning objectives that
we we had at the start and what I really
hope is that you have now Come Away with
a a much better understanding of the
kind of state-of-the-art applications of
using AI insights but you also should
hopefully understand much more deeply
how these algorithms work how you can
design them and and how uh and the
theory behind them as
well hopefully you also real you're
realistic in that we can't just apply AI
to think it's not a sledg handmer there
are pros and cons of using especially
deep newal networks in these scientific
workflows and there's a lot of other
kind of broader Concepts and themes in
this field of SEL that for example like
the power of a auto differentiation and
and where you should learn your
components of your system uh but
hopefully you've taken away in this
course
um so yeah this is how how it looked we
we learned about pins and we did
operator learning then we did
Transformers and then we've done a lot
of work on these kind of hybrid
workflows and all differential equations
and and model
Discovery and as we've gone through I
was we were kind of showing you that you
can put kind of scientific understanding
it in many different parts of your
machine learning workflows it can be
like through the loss function it can be
through the architecture design or it
could be more tightly integrated into
our traditional scientific workflows and
that's kind of what's really amazing
about siml is that there's so many
different opportunities to to
incorporate science into our machine
learning algorithms
um so skip this so I think I've just
kind of settled this this is quite a
heavy slide but this is pretty much
everything I just said so there are
definitely pros and cons of using deep
learning in your in your workflows you
have to be aware of them and and not
just use it
naively but in general adding scientific
understanding to ml um usually improves
performance of our of our
workplace
um so I just have one final slide which
is a super high level slide but I think
it's people often ask me what's a good
good place to like research and SC
science and machine learning uh or what
are impactful directions in the future I
mean this is a sort of slide which is
both quite useful but also not very
useful because it's so high
level but I just want to draw a
connection here between uh you know
things that we care about applications
that we care about in science and
applications that we care about in in AI
and the kind of well you can boil it
down to at a super high level it's kind
of two big goals that we really want to
try and solve and for sure there are
massive outstanding challenges that we
haven't solved in these directions yet
and and this is where I think the most
impactful research can be done and these
kind of kind of tasks search and
optimization and
representation um and if you think about
it in science we have these these
problems like inverse model problems
model Discovery control it's all us High
level just be thought of like a search
problem like we have some goal and we
want to search for some inputs or some
parameters to achieve that goal we
actually have the same in AI right we
have planning we want to create plans we
want to do some reasoning or even just
learning is a is a can be thought of as
a search
problem so Des thinking about doing
research and search or optimization like
how do we design good search algorithms
that have good prior understanding just
as I've been talking about for symbolic
regression coming up with those can
really impact across science and AI
depending on where you want to to have
impact and then the other the other big
topic is representation and in science
this is basically the statement as
everyone has everyone heard the the
quote every model is approximate but
some are useful like this really
famous so what that's really saying is
like we only have a finite amount of
computing power to like do to for
example solve a PD like we have to
choose some representation or some
approximation of system and and that is
the fundamental question is what is the
right approximation to use uh like when
we're talking about operator learning
like what is the basis that we're going
to use is it like a 4E basis or is it
something else like these have massive
impacts in the um in the performance of
the scientific code for example in
finite element methods like what is the
basis function we use or how should we
use it how should we discre our mesh
like all these sort of
things and the same kind of questions
occur in AI so we talk about
representation it's obviously super
important like at what level is llm
reasoning is it reasoning about simple
features or is it abstracting and
telling it like understands what the
principle of like thermodynamics is or
something like this you
know uh the latest kind of planning
algorithms in AO for example use like
hierarchical representations that uh to
be able to like attractively search the
world around us so again thinking about
representation at a very deep level will
help you impact both of these these
different
fields so yeah useful but also not
useful but uh hopefully that's given you
some inspiration to to carry on and do
research so thank you very much for
being part of the course I hope you took
something away from it and that you
enjoy the lectures next week given by
David so yeah he'll be there yeah thank
you very much